So Trulin you mentioned that you have a European ancestry background
which didn't surprise you too much, but I really liked to
know about your paternal lines. So from your Y chromosome, do
you mind logging in and showing us what it looks like?
>> No, not at all. Show us what
to navigate to get to this information. so basically
you go to My Results and then you go
to, under Ancestry Overview you go to Paternal Line.
>> So what does it say? What are you?
>> I am R1b1b2a2a 2f2.
>> That is a mouthful.
>> It is. Which is a subgroup of R1b1b2.
>> And so, where is this from? Where does this take us?
>> it says that around 500 years ago, before the era
of intercontinental travel, I was predominantly from the
Southern European area. And it looks like there are some spots other
places too, like maybe even less so like the Middle East and some.
>> Yeah.
>> Western parts of Asia.
>> Right.
>> this is, is this what you
expected? Did you expect anything? is this surprising?
>> It's a little surprising. I mean, I
thought like both my maternal and paternal line
will be primarily all from the Northern European
sections, but this is showing the Southern European section
with a lot of spread out into other areas.
>> So, what kinds of populations does it say
this Y chromosome paternal and half a group per pattern.
>> So, if you look at it here, it
says that the populations are Irish, Basque, British and French.